jacob rees-mogg is a boris johnson
loyalist he was backing the prime
minister right to the end writing in
today's sunday express he compares the
ousting of the prime minister to the
slaying of julius caesar and said that
those who betrayed boris will now seek
to neuter brexit well the brexit
opportunities minister now has to decide
who he wants to replace boris johnson he
joins us now
live thank you very much for being on
the programme
first things first it feels like pretty
much everyone in the conservative party
fancies a crack at the top job can you
rule yourself out
well um
john lydon better name as johnny rotten
has kindly
endorsed me but he's not a member of the
conservative party i was very flattered
that he should suggest my name no like
david davis i am looking for
a candidate who will deliver the
policies uh that will ensure a
successful conservative government that
is my interest in this leadership
campaign and have you made your mind up
then who you're backing
no not yet we're beginning to see people
come out and set out their stalls but we
need someone who will be clear about
their principles
who will not have any baggage says to
speak
and
who
will be able to win both with the
conservative party at large and in a
general election
which is obviously from a conservative
point of view not just in the party's
interest but in the national interest
okay and if you've got a short list
of people
um well we haven't yet got all the names
so i think we'll have to wait and see
what all the names are there are some
good candidates who have come forward um
i was sorry that ben wallace decided to
withdraw i thought he was potentially a
very good candidate
so we'll have to see where where we get
to uh in the coming hours and even
a couple of days
do you think that the next leader of the
conservative party needs to be someone
who backed brexit
i think it's very important that
brexit has been done legally but there
is a great deal of work to do to get the
benefits of brexit to make the uk a less
regulated freer market that isn't in
lockstep with the european union part of
that is delivering on the northern
ireland protocol and i think the bill
before parliament at the moment
is a very good way of doing that so it
needs to be somebody who will support
that
but in my current role
not all ministers have embraced with
enthusiasm the advantages of brexit
within their own departments and that's
really important because that's where
the advantages lie
who are you talking about
um well i'm talking about the retained
eu law bill where we're trying to ensure
that all uk law by um 2026 ideally
possibly 2028
should cease to have supremacy and
should be
in line with uk law and uk law should be
our ruling force and there have been
some departments um the treasury wants
to keep tax as something that is still
subject to the idea of supremacy of eu
law who haven't adopted that with
enthusiasm and therefore i am concerned
that there are obstacles
and it's important to have people who
are wholehearted uh in their support of
brexit
i mean russia soon to be fair did
actually vote for brexit he he believes
in brexit well i
i wasn't really referring to chancellor
himself i was referring to the
institution of the treasury which i
think is one of the problems that we
have
in this country i think as david davis
was saying the treasury has got our
economic policy wrong with its
high tax approach and its failure to
understand the benefits of growth
the treasury in the interim between
rishi sunak and nadim zahawi properly
taking control
managed an attempt to kibosh uh the
public sector fraud authority because
it's embarrassed about the fraud that
has taken place affecting the treasury
so i think the treasury as an
institution is a real problem
and i would hope that any future leader
will tackle that so that it's under
proper political control it's difficult
isn't it because you know there's been
an awful lot of scrutiny about tax
policy hasn't there um lots of
candidates throwing around some very
eye-catching uh tax cuts i'm sure go
down very well
with conservative party members and but
at the same time you know
tax costs cost money and whether it's
spending cuts or adding to the debt uh
looking at what just what richie sue
next said recently you know i have a
responsibility to make sure we don't
burden our children with a legacy of
debt that i didn't deal with and that's
why i've had to make some decisions
which i know are not always popular
are you concerned that actually you know
in the leadership contest in the quest
for popularity people are being a bit
irresponsible
well i think random tax cuts drawn out
of a hat is not the way to approach this
i think we need a well thought through
economic policy based on how we tackle
inflation
and i think there is a place for tax
cuts within that
that if you think what ronald reagan did
in the 1980s there was a tight monetary
policy there was tight control of
expenditure and there was lower taxes
but the tax lawyering was done on a
reform of taxation to make it simpler to
have fewer exemptions to taxation so
there were fewer
means of getting around it fewer means
of legitimately avoiding tax but with
lower rates
i i think that's what we should be
looking at rather than plucking random
tax cuts out of the air
but there are detailed things you can do
if you take fuel duty
and we pay more in tax on fuel because
of the way vat is geared as the price
goes up so the treasury makes a profit
from higher fuel prices
which actually is a burden on the
economy do we really want to do that is
the gain the treasury is making a
proportionate one does it really want to
get more tax on petrol as prices go up
now i just want to talk a little bit
about uh boris johnson and you've
obviously has been one of his staunchest
defenders you were there in downing
street listening to him as he gave his
resignation a statement
now last week you described boris
johnson's mistakes as prime minister as
relatively minor missteps it got taken
out of all proportion
i mean we're talking about the handling
of sexual assault here aren't we do you
think that sounds a bit flippant
no no i don't because i believe in the
principle that somebody is innocent
until proved guilty
and they the reports of what mr pincher
has done
sound very serious
they have gone from
sounding as if somebody was too drunk
and behaved badly to a sexual assault
that is a different
category and when the prime minister was
first talking about it or his spokesman
was first talking about it
it sounded like somebody who was very
drunk
but the principle of innocence until
proved guilty is is fundamental
uh and mr pinter is entitled to due
process that that's a constitutional
fundamental i don't think anyone is
necessarily saying i don't think
anyone's necessarily saying that chris
pincher wasn't entitled to due process
but i think it was rather whether or not
people were entitled to know the full
facts about what number 10 knew and when
when he was made
when he was given the job
well dare i say in this current
leadership election there is all sorts
of gossip running wild about all sorts
of people none of which is known are we
to be a society that whenever there is a
little bit of gossip
excludes people from their ability to be
a member of parliament i i think we need
facts and there weren't facts there was
a degree of gossip and there was the
foreign office incident which had been
closed down there had been an accepted
apology and and the difficulty with that
is that if an apology has been accepted
you don't know at that point how serious
it was it may turn out later that it was
more serious
but it was something that was was closed
the evidence wasn't there
for the prime minister in my mind to
have made a fair decision um otherwise
okay um interesting to hear your taker
on that definitely and just finally
there are reports that boris johnson is
thinking about creating some new periods
in the next few months so do you think
that's acceptable uh to do well he's a
caretaker prime minister
well
any privileges that are created in the
next few months if there are any and i
don't know about this it would have been
in the pipeline for a long time
appearages don't just get created
because the pm wakes up in the morning
and says i will have a peer the letters
patent do say their peerage is created
by the emotion of the queen
to get from
the initial idea through to her
majesty's emotion
is quite a long-winded process